hi reject nation it's greg alpha here
and john hump so we are going to watch a
video today called dr. who you're shamed
from a channel called margarita life now
RI well we have a patreon like many a
youtubers and one of our reward tiers
over at patreon whatever video you
request we must definitely do majority
at a time it's a reaction that's okay
and this comes from a man named Nathan
Wilton who lives all the way in
Australia he is very charming
good-looking guy who gets plenty of
[ __ ] all the time he drinks a lot
he's probably gonna throw his life away
after it becomes massively successful
because he's constantly getting promoted
that took guts I'm promoting you
it doesn't stop drinking so would you
live it up with him while you can girls
because before you know it he's gonna be
washed up on the beach so happy to have
you be a part of our patreon Nathan I
would never says to your faces look like
he could kick my ass any moment of the
day anyway I was thought and we don't
watch Doctor Who will be be confused and
I have a suspicion he's trying to
persuade us to watch Doctor Who and
that's why he's like no you know my
patron request is gonna be this one I
have a feeling we're gonna be peer
pressured and starting a new show soon
and we could watch you know a thousand
episodes of Doctor Who in a year no
problem we had that time totally
including all the lost episodes
apparently there are hundreds of lost
episodes I'll make time series make time
all right let's check this bad boy out
and by the way we start sweating our air
conditionings broken right now and
putting a thermostat here it's uh 85
degrees in the apartment we got lights
pointed in everything you know it's just
visually very nice let's get to it never
seen even a moment of Doctor Who's I've
seen nine I'll help you
my good man doctor the way all three and
why is my ranking stood up to you to
save us quite a good complex you have
there well if you were really old and
really kind in alone your whole race
dead no future what couldn't you do that
and then we discovered one why this
doctor who had fought that gods and
demons why he'd run away from us and
hidden he was being kind
your people were peaceful to the point
of indolence you seemed to be something
new because once in a while on a whim if
the winds in the right direction happens
become yes he must have been like God
the man who could turn an army around at
the mention of his name he's like fire
and ice and rage stand too close and
people get burned if the doctor never
visited accident never chose this place
[Music]
those the conscience of the doctor or
his shame you're ashamed
you don't watch it happen I'm a bit
awkward what did it feel like that seems
like a really sad guy crime that would
science the universe too might not
represent us do you think I wanted this
winning I see
Dalek hey and when people come to you
and ask you trying to get to be with the
people I love is it anyway good idea
this is your lunch box
myself and I've just told me we are
declaring the universe and you will lead
us into battle negative leaves used to
realize the laws of time are mine
yeah
really
all the people died because of my messy
Diamond goes to
[Music]
[Music]
this is what you made of me is that what
you to turn turn into a soldier
hey long time now I thought I was just
inspired
playing with certain many people's lives
he might as well be a God why don't why
not how long have you been traveling
alone see this is what happens when you
travel alone for too long there will be
consequences for you changing into all
those years ago sailing off to see the
universe did you ever think you'd become
this this is wrong I don't care who you
bother if you carry on the way you are
that was contantly
telling to her
you just forget it I'm the doctor
I've lived for over 2,000 years I've
made many mistakes it's about time that
I did something about that because that
saying yeah kind of confused this is the
closest to picking up on the style and
the concept of the show that I've ever
seen
okay I thought it was kind of like a
bond thing with the show no I
but apparently the doctor has lived for
that long and they just they change it
every season yeah people like I didn't I
didn't catch on to that they changed the
rules just recently because the show is
still popular so it used to be that
there could be twelve regenerations or
something like that the doctor can
regenerate twelve times and now they've
reached more than 12 times so they've
obviously changed that rule but yeah
like a lot of people like to bring up
this sort of whimsical idea that James
Bond is a Time Lord and it's not
different actors of different people
have the same character regenerated
because of doctor yeah cuz I kept
flashing a bond when I was looking at
this yeah and this is only four of the
doctors out of you know I guess what was
hooking me the most I mean other than
the fact that was like it's super sci-fi
one of the things I was really hooking
me was unlike bond where I didn't feel
like I got emotional until Daniel Craig
[Music]
it seems like every version a doctor who
requires like a really great actor who's
very emotionally intense and who can
also do a lot of whimsy I mean I've only
seen effectively I've only seen one
whole season or two if you're going by
British series and so from what I
understand Christopher Eccleston is the
one I've seen is kind of a darker doctor
as compared to perhaps a David Tennant
or a Matt Smith but even him like each
of them has a whimsical side and the
episodes have wait but they're also fun
and they're also kind of cheeky as well
and and of course you know the further
you get into the season when the
serialize story kicks in things get a
bit darker but yeah interesting
Wow this seems like one compel
journey that would give me a lot of
anxiety starting from episode 1 yes
thinking I have to finish this you know
well I mean everybody liked it what
everyone told me cuz I was the same way
I was I start at the beginning everyone
was like no no no no start at season 1
of the new series see how you feel and
then go back to the old stuff cuz really
because the production values are so
different cuz also from where this show
came from like a lot of the early
episodes are like blast in black box
theaters with like sheep effects and
stuff like that and like the stories are
good but that's why I feel like I should
start there because when I started bond
at the beginning I had already seen all
of the Pierce Brosnan adage of cracklins
so to go to like dr. know was like this
is kind of hard because it's so much
more and I feel like I have this similar
problem of being introduced to something
that's very modern and easy to for me to
latch on to you to readjust your mindset
for the time this was shot you know five
fair I mean the only thing is it's gonna
take you maybe never getting to these
guys doctors you know and these I don't
know I've heard we're shooting reactions
for it
what yeah but it's gonna take like 10
years to get hundreds of old episodes
not just the new ones there are hundreds
of the old episodes plus movie like the
eighth doctor is only in a movie or
something like that
there are lost episodes that you can
basically read the plot breakdown Spore
but you can actually how many episodes
are there season there can't be a lot
one doctor can go for multiple seasons
like Eccleston did to series by the
British Standard David Tennant was from
2005-2010 Matt Smith did three or four
seasons you know look there's only 800
total Doctor Who that I've aired okay
okay maybe I won't start from the
beginning I mean I can definitely see
the merit of going back for maybe some
of the highlights are especially going
back to see Tom Bay 36 seasons
yeah it's do they have like multiple
Doctor Who shows running at once not
well not I don't know that side is well
up until the recent times worse
there was the Torchwood spin-off there
or some other video is Greg questioning
John about Doctor Who knowledge to which
he is only see what do you if you're
going I'm British I don't know I mean I
try to pick up as many facts as possible
but the other fun part about you looks
like Karen Gillan is one of the
Companions so she's on several episodes
but we also saw Maisie Williams I don't
know exactly what her involvement is but
part of the fun also is you'll see tons
of awesome okay how long are the
episodes the new ones are you know like
42 minutes
okay let's 840 times 45 37 thousand
eight hundred minutes divided by sixty
six hundred thirty hours
yeah only how many hours in a year 8760
well that's yeah you'd have eight
thousand one hundred odd you know okay
so remember the number okay 630 all
right 8,000 divided by 630 thirteen
point nine fourteen let's call it
fourteen number does nothing for some
amount of doctor whose factors in the
amount of hours in a year or somehow by
this oh if I watch 14 hours of Doctor
Who it's a finish this is one year just
drop everything and dedicate your life
for a year Wow okay there's gotta be a
math way to figure out how many I should
watch a week oh yeah to finish it in
five years and by that time 20 new
doctors the new season starts a couple
weeks that's amazing I hate you Nathan
Wilson I mean I love you because you're
part of our patreon page I hate you
because now I feel I mean is it like
hyper serialized can I just watch the
ones I wanna watch it's a pretty
episodic and because each doctor
eventually regenerates there are serial
arcs like there's a there's a background
story running wall but each episode is
kind of monster of the week as was
because I love you know David Tennant
his kilgrave and is some people's
favorite D easily when I was watching
this I was like will the 1i really watch
like I was Tennant and this guy the one
who looks like friggin people love I've
heard some people say that over the new
ones he is perhaps the best in terms of
the spirit of the doctor I mean I like
Christopher Eccleston a lot and the good
thing about his season is if you don't
love him it's the shortest of the new
ones I believe okay cuz he only did like
eight eight to ten episodes okay you get
a lot of time with David Tennant and
I've seen a couple of those and he's got
his own spin and it's a lot of fun to
watch and also you know you get a ton of
great guest actors too and because of
the way just what the doctor does you
get different time periods different
creatures all sorts of stuff this is
this too is like as far as compilations
go this is mostly highlighting the
dramatic heavy and kind of not hinting
at the fun in the in the fantasy and all
that stuff which is just as much a part
you know well guys do you watch Doctor
Who have you seen all 840 episodes that
have aired leave it in the comments
below and tell me how you found it time
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
yeah you can check us on patreon we've
got TV show reactions q and A's not for
Doctor Who don't want to miss anyone
there